who in your life are you trying to
please meaning your life are you
trying to hear the magical words I'm
proud of you right like are there
certain names on that list now you may
say I don't need to please anybody I do
I have a list and I'm very comfortable
with it and you should have a list as
well and some tells me you do but let's
unpack this whole concept of who to
please who not to please and what
happens when you succeed if you get
value from this video give it a thumbs
up subscribe to the channel let's get
right into it so I want to give a quick
shout out to our sponsor Aura this is
very important for you to take advantage
of a service like this you know my son's
Instagram right now I'm going back and
forward to getting his Instagram account
back my sister had her Instagram taken
down we have a bunch of people in-house
here when they went on aura.com one of
our guys had 41 of their passwords on
the dark web that others are using this
is becoming a very common thing right
now 53 billion dollars is how much it
costs last year on cyber crime cyber
theft today officially passed robbery
home robberies first time ever in the
history of America that this is
happening and for you to protect
yourself I highly recommend you take
advantage of Aura one it secures your
online accounts IDs and personal info to
prevent Financial losses with fast fraud
alerts three stop viruses from stealing
your info and last but not least keep
your online activities secure and
private so to take advantage of this go
to aura.com forward slash valuetainment
to get a two weeks free trial once again
aura.com forward slash value 10 you'll
get two weeks free as we succeed as you
succeed somehow someway you're gonna
have more people in your life because
with more success you have a bigger team
you need more people to help you out
right so you got more team members more
support more customers more clients it's
just kind of how this thing works and
when you start winning you're in new
communities you make new friends you
know if you get married you know her
friends his friends your friends kids
parents kids friends parents you're in
all these different communities right
and then you know gradually what happens
is you reach a certain level which is
kind of confusing for certain people
it's called guilt management and so some
of the people who maybe you knew when
you were in high school I got a message
from a guy like I get messages from guys
from high school do you remember we were
best friends and I I remember people I
don't remember this guy being best
friends I think we had one class
together and I know my friends that were
close friends but we were you don't have
time for anybody you don't have time for
this guilt management guilt management
guilt management is going to happen to
you over and over and over and over
again what do you do with that
you're winning you have more money you
have more success oh you've changed all
you care about is money you follow
yourself now sometimes it is true
sometimes it's not sometimes money just
makes you more of what you are if you
were full of yourself when you were 17
years old and you were an now
you're 42 you're following yourself you
just got more money you still follow
yourself but if you were chill you were
cool you were good to be around when you
were 17 years old you're just chill cool
good to be around you just were 10
million 5 million you have more money
right that's money is going to make you
more of what you are right now so how do
you handle this guilt management how do
you manage all these people today trying
to please just because you succeeded you
know more people the amount of people
you please should decrease Sunday night
I'm sitting down having a conversation
with Mario and Mario just got married
and you know we're having a conversation
about what things he has to do now to
make sure his marriage works out
becomes a good father he becomes a good
husband he becomes a good leader you
know you can't try to please everybody
in your family at what cost your
marriage at what cost your relationship
with your kid no I want
to make my kids proud I love my kids a
lot I want to make these four kids proud
right I don't care to be perfect so if
they're going to be like solving me to
be perfect I don't solve for Perfection
I don't have the standard of perfection
for anybody in my life but I want you to
become a leader that's my standards
right but I want to make my kids proud I
want to make my family proud I want to
make my you know a short list of people
that matter to me proud it's not a long
list it's a short list the most people
the people that are a hundred percent
loyal to our vision it's very important
to me to make them proud because that's
a relationship and it's very emotional
for you to bind to the vision of what
we're doing whether I ran an insurance
company or I'm running a media company
it doesn't matter if you're 100 loyal I
want to make you proud to say you made
the right decision being loyal to the
cousin helping the company get to the
next level those people matter because
it takes a lot of effort to be at that
level but do I want to please everybody
no do I want to please every you know
person that's ever been in our lives
know every relative definitely not why
not it's impossible
it's impossible you try to do that you
will not live a happy life other people
will try to get sucked all the energy
out of you you will not live a happy
life you know who you should never
explain yourself to you know this whole
concept they'll tell so tell me why you
were late I got into a car accident on
the way here here's a picture here's
where I was at look at the time at the
top 738 Pat I'm never late you know what
you're right cool you're good everybody
get a backpack everything's good I'm
here I'm gonna get the things done you
mind if I take an hour to go get the car
situated because honey do your thing
because there is that right now people
who you can't ever do anything right in
their eyes guess what never explain
yourself to them let me say this one
more time to you people in your life
that you can never do anything right in
their eyes and they use guilt against
you never explain to yourself can I ask
you guys why you did that no we just did
everything that's good no I want to know
what happened no I don't need to explain
it to you we made our choice because
this reason and you move
but the people you love the people who
have your back the people that are loyal
to the people that go above and beyond
for you the people that believe in you
the people that challenge you do it if
they're able to reason with you can ask
you why the deadline didn't happen on WE
screwed up man it's all good can we make
sure we hit it tomorrow we're probably
gonna hit it tomorrow next time can you
tell me if you got too much bandwidth
that you can't handle like your
bandwidth isn't there let us know
because it's important for us at the
time totally get it I screwed up my
fault won't happen again great when two
people reason and you explain
Solutions you know you come up with a
solution when two people can't reason
and one's using guilt you're going to be
constant feel like you're already idiot
here you're not this person's using
guilt against you only reason with
people that have the ability to reason
make sense so going back to it you
succeed more people enter in your life
phenomenal awesome fewer people you
should try to please and uh that list
should be a very very small list if you
want to enjoy the process of doing
something big with your life if you got
value out of this video give it a thumbs
up and subscribe to the channel also if
you enjoyed this video I got another one
for you to watch Tyler I wish I knew
this earlier click here to watch it take
care everybody bye
foreign
[Music]